seht ihr in eurer nachbarschaft manchmal
auch geschäfte mit ganz skurrilen namen
heute stellen wir euch mal unsere
lieblings geschäfte hier in berlin vor
los geht's die absatz pankow glänzt mit
einem ganz besonderen wortspiel denn das
hier ist ein schuh
reparaturservice im stile einer bar und
der absatz ist übrigens das was man
manchmal war höheren schuhen unter dem
schuh hat
wilde frisur garantiert beim tsunami
friseur im deutschen gibt es diesen
schönen pazifistischen spruch leben und
leben lassen und diese buchhandlung
heißt passend dazu lesen und lesen
lassen
anders als im bürgeramt muss man im
bürgeramt nicht lange warten es gibt
keine unfreundliche bedienung und man
bekommt sogar noch was er am ende
nämlich einen burger im deutschen gibt
es einen spruch den man sagt wenn jemand
sich nicht gut ernährt oder vielleicht
nicht genug ist dann sagt man du kannst
nicht nur von luft und liebe leben
dieses motto hat sich dieses café oder
diese bar hier direkt zum anlass
genommen und hat sich luft und liebe
bahn genannt
der antiquitätenhandel general nachlass
marschall benutzt das witzige wortspiel
in der kombination des militärischen
rangs general marschall und dem nachlass
das ist ein wort für die dinge die übrig
sind wenn ein mensch stirbt und etwas
zurück lässt
monarchie und alltag
möbel und stoffe
[Musik]
manche leute gehen in die kneipe um sich
nach einem langen harten tag zu
entspannen andere leute gehen in die
cocktailbar
adrenalin
hier gibt's passion für damen und herren
im bekleidungsgeschäft mode und move
[Musik]
mindestens tausend dinge gibt's im
geschäft tausend dinge
keine paradoxe kombination playstation
und shisha in der playstation und shisha
lounge paradox hier bekommst du immer
was du möchtest in der kneipe du bist
dran happy hour sonntags 10 bis 12 uhr
hier ist alles top secret
im eiscafé
geheimwaffe
sucht er noch nach einem lustigen namen
für euer geschäft eine clevere
kombination zwischen deutsch und
englisch ist immer eine gute idee so wie
hier zum beispiel in der bäckerei und
bistro feed back oder
hier im friseursalon
hereinspaziert hereinspaziert
hereinspaziert
oder auch hier beim friseur come to cut
hier gibt es ganz herrliche frisuren
beim friseur
herrlich hier gibt es nicht nur neue
haare sondern auch gute stimmung im
haarsalon ab muss her
zeit für eine kleine pause und zeit um
euch den sponsor des heutigen videos
vorzustellen und das ist nord wpm nord
vpn ist ein service mit dem ihr und wir
sicher im internet surfen können und
nicht nur das mit nord bpn könnt ihr
auch eure ip-adresse maskieren um aus
einem anderen land zu surfen wenn ihr
zum beispiel in den usa seit oder in
indien oder australien und ihr möchtet
auf inhalte in deutschland zugreifen die
für euch geblockt sind dann könnt ihr
nord pvn einschalten und euch mit einer
deutschen ip adresse verbinden um sodann
in deutschland zu surfen das ist zum
beispiel dann nützlich wenn ihr zum
beispiel die mediatheken der großen
deutschen fernsehsender angucken möchte
oder vielleicht wenn ihr das deutsche
netflix angebote sehen möchte probiert
das mal aus nord wpm hat jetzt einen
großen rabatt für alle die sich durch
unseren code anmelden der heißt easy
german oder ihr könnt direkt über die
website gehen nord wie pr.com / german
und dann erhaltet ihr einen großen
rabatt auf das 2 jahres paket einen
monat gratis und ihr könnt das auch
einfach mal 30 tage testen mit der geld
zurück garantie
[Musik]
deutschlands land der wortspiele hier
gibt es nicht nur lecker döner sondern
auch gute laune im bistro hoch zwei
italien italien pizzeria pizzeria
manche geschäfte überzeugen auch einfach
durch einen absurd langen namen wie zum
beispiel die schneiderei kleider klinik
und reinigung
eine sache die mir speziell in berlin
aufgefallen ist sind die riesigen nahmen
über arztpraxen tier arztpraxen oder
zahnarztpraxen ich kenne das so aus
meiner heimatstadt dass das eigentlich
nur so ein schild ist am eingang und da
steht dann zahnarzt doktor sowieso aber
in berlin sehe ich das ganz oft das
einfach in riesigen buchstaben dasteht
arzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erst habe ich gedacht ein drink haase
dann habe ich das so gesehen und dachte
ich na klar die drinks
dann habe ich aber immer den hasen
gesehen
entscheidet ihr drink hase oder drink
oase
[Musik]
janosch hat nachgefragt
was ist das für ein name keiner weiß das
wirklich aber die vermutung geht dahin
dass es zuerst trinkt oase geheißen hat
und dann irgendjemand nach dem dritten
oder vierten bier darauf gekommen ist
dass das genauso gut oder vielleicht
noch besser trinkt hasel heißen könnte
und so ist es offensichtlich dann auch
geblieben
hier gibt es nicht nur frisuren sondern
auch drinks in der hna
das ist wirklich einer meiner lieblings
nahmen das kaffeehaus kuchen rausch
das café
internet so
eine gute zeit hat man auch immer in der
sportsbar
eiscafé
surprise ein besonders
vielversprechender name die fahrschule
sachs es
hier sehen wir wahrscheinlich den grund
warum sich die drinks ase im ring haase
umbenannt hat die richtige drink oase
hier haben wir den multi shop eisen
krane wir haben keine ahnung was das
bedeuten könnte aber janisch geht jetzt
für euch rein und fragt nach
so da kam diana china ja nicht was ist
der multi shop eisen kann
also es verbirgt sich eine unglaubliche
geschichten geschichte dahinter und zwar
ein
mensch hatte dort ein geschäft ein
mensch der in krieg eine hand verloren
hat und er hat sich dann so eine eiserne
kahle
anfertigen lassen und allen lernten ihn
auch eisen kralle und auch das geschäft
was hierher besessen hat hat man quasi
beim reisen gerade genannt oder reisen
kann und
1970 wurde dieses geschäft übernommen
aber die neuen besitzer
erhielten den namen einfach falsch weil
der so allgemein bekannt war und witzig
wohnt ihr in deutschland und kennt auch
lustige geschäftsnamen in eurer umgebung
dann freuen wir uns wenn ihr lust habt
uns die zu schicken denn wir denken dass
wir bisher nur einen kleinen kleinen
teil der lustigsten geschäftsnamen in
berlin gezeigt haben aber in anderen
städten gibt es ja auch lustige
geschäftsnamen und wenn ihr lust haben
mitzumachen dann macht doch einfach ein
foto und von dem geschäft dass ihr seht
und schickt dieses foto zu uns nämlich
über unsere website unter easy german
york / fanny schopfheims die domain
posten wir auch noch mal hier unten
dankeschön fürs zu sehen und bis bald
[Musik]